avec eric le fer avec yannick lefebvre
bonjour yannick lefebvre
merci beaucoup à vous bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france on a entendu madame
simoneau qui est rapporteur justement de
ce qui se passe dans les prisons à dire
qu' il y avait des clusters dans dans
les prisons et c'était assez inquiétant
quelle est la situation pouvait vous la
décrire dans votre prison à côté nous
sortons justement d'un cluster qui a été
assez fort puisque nous avons eu le
variant angles et qui rentraient sur
l'établissement de nombreux personnels
de surveillance et personnels extérieurs
ont été impactés sur sur l'établissement
la propagation s'est répandue de jour en
jour
depuis deux jours nous sommes plus en
cluster malgrès que nous avons encore
constaté de nouveaux cas ce qui est
extrêmement difficile le contexte des
prisons est assez complexe
nous avons beaucoup de brassage beaucoup
de personnel une côtoyons beaucoup de
personnes détenues malgrè la première
vague où il ya eu une forte baisse de
l'effectif des personnes détenues nous
avons par able par exemple sur le cpe
longuenesse quasiment plus de 100
détenus en moins ce qui nous a fait un
grand bien ce qui a aussi permis de
pouvoir ré réduire les risques fort
heureusement nous n'avons eu que très
peu de détenus qui ont contracté le
virus
malheureusement c'est le personnel qui
en souffrent personnel qui est en manque
de personnel sur un établissement comme
le nôtre et qui a un surcroît d'activité
tout ça lié avec aussi leur et les
risques psychosociaux des personnels
puisqu'ils ils ont peur de prendre le
virus au travail
malgré tout les consignes de notre
administration qui nous impose le port
du masque la distanciation tout ça c'est
assez complexe
justement comment est ce que vous vous
travaillez au quotidien par exemple un
détenu testé positif comment ça se passe
bien protocole de deux prévus il va être
isolé alors sur notre établissement le
chef d'établissement et les
organisations syndicales ont été conviés
dès la première vague l'arrivée du virus
et des mesures ont été prises pour
libérer des places sur certains
quartiers afin de pouvoir isoler les
arrivants qui viennent de l'extérieur
qui seront confinés par le service
médical et qui seront testés dans les
plus brefs délais à l'issue du test il
reste en 14 elle si il s'avère que le
ter stress négatif ils peuvent rejoindre
la détention classique
s'ils sont positifs ils restent dans cl
qui sont spécialement mise en place pour
les qu'ovide et comment est-ce que ces
vécus par les détenus est ce que ça ça
rajoute évidemment du stress
supplémentaire pour eux comment ça se
passe
à écouter sur l'arrivée du virus ça a
été extrêmement compliqué on a dû nous
les personnels à être très pédago
pédagogie pardon nous avons essayé de
leur faire comprendre que c'était aussi
pour eux et que le virus
ils étaient treize ans et s'était mis
qui tu dis on leur a mené donc c'était
leur crainte principale c'est que une
bonne partie des personnes détenues
était conscient de ce qui se passait à
l'extérieur mais craignait surtout que
nous leur amenons voilà alors il y a il
ya aussi dans les centres de détention
des des personnes à risque détenus des
détenus âgés par exemple qu'en est il de
la de la vaccination est ce qu'il ya une
une campagne qui est prévu dans les
prisons comment est-ce que ça se passe
bah écoute et à l'art depuis quelques
jours on a notre administration qui a
demandé aux chefs d'établissement et au
service médical de se rapprocher des
détenus dits à risque pour pouvoir leur
mettre en place un plan de vaccination
pour l'instant ils ne sont pas vaccinés
pour l'instant personne n'a été vaccinés
a pour l'instant notamment nous sur
notre établissement dont personne n'a
encore été vaccinés et pourrait
justement pour le personnel de
l'administration pénitentiaire d'une
campagne de vaccination également qui
est prévu ou pas à réécouter c'est ça a
été extrêmement difficile pour les
personnels de surveillance notamment sur
l'établissement de découvrir
on se rapprocher les personnes détenues
alors que nous sur l'établissement
l'administration n'a pour l'instant fait
appel à personne pour pouvoir se faire
vacciner alors c'était un peu compliqué
malgrès que la vaccination est le
protocole est mis et housses aussi
également à l'extérieur mais nous
aimerions aussi être contacté par notre
administration pour nous proposer un
vaccin
il y a un papa forcément dans votre
prison mais un problème de surpopulation
carcérale il ya de plus en plus de
détenus
vous pensez que la politique du
gouvernement qui consistait à à libérer
à ouvrir les prisons était la bonne en
71 me bah écoutez notre organisation
syndicale comme d'autres plaident depuis
de nombreuses années pour
l'encellulement individuel
nous avons réclamé à l'issue de 2018 la
création de nouvelles places de prison
malheureusement nous n'avons pas encore
vu ces place se libérait nous avons eu
comme beaucoup d'établissements une
grosse baisse des effectifs de personnes
détenues puisque nous avons plus de cent
100 détenus qui sont en moi sur
l'établissement
certes sur les maisons d'arrêt ya encore
énormément population puisque vous
pouvez le constater vous aussi la
délinquance ne s'arrête pas avec le co
reid
donc oui il ya une forte baisse
malheureusement l'encellulement
individuel extrêmement compliqué surtout
sur des établissements comme le nôtre où
nous avons dû libérer aussi de l'espace
pour mettre à disposition pour les
arrivants et les testées positives qu
vide merci beaucoup
yannick lefebvre d'avoir témoigné sur
notre antenne ce matin je le rappelle
vous faites partie du syndicat ufap unsa
au centre pénitentiaire de longuenesse